I'd like to start off by thanking Merkin
company for endow lling the Skolnick
prize in neuroscience it was endowed by
Merck in honor of its skull neck
conserved for 17 years as head of Merck
research labs now as many of you know
the endowment has grown in value over
the years and now consists of this
fantastic McGovern Institute hug which
will be presented to the Prize winner
tonight and happy april fools
I am very very happy to say that this
year's prize winter and the future mug
owner is Tom Jessel the Clair toe
professor of biochemistry molecular
biophysics and neuroscience at Columbia
the co-director of the colleague mine
brain initiative at Columbia and Howard
Hughes investigator Tom received his PhD
from Cambridge University and has spent
most of his professional career at
Columbia he's a member of the US
National Academy of Sciences member of
the Royal Society and he's won many
other awards for his work including the
bristol-myers Squibb award the Kavli
prize and the Garrett Gairdner award now
there's probably no more fascinating or
important problem area in neuroscience
than how the brain forms during
development how does a an embryonic cell
know what kind of neuron to become how
does it integrate itself into local
neural networks and how does it form all
the appropriate connections with neurons
throughout the brain so that it can
mediate our great behavioral complexity
Tom Jessel has used the spinal cord in
this work as a model system it is is
used it because of its simplicity and
the evolutionary conservation which
makes it really an ideal system for
studying the general principles of
neural development
that's just a few examples he discovered
the morphogens the fusible molecules
that determine whether cells in the
spinal cord become century related
neurons in the dorsal cord or motor
related neurons in the ventral cord he's
discovered the master regulators and
hawks gene family that determined how
cells acquire their particular
properties and all their their central
and peripheral connections and he's used
this knowledge to manipulate the
different cell groups to understand that
link between the functional neural
circuitry and motor behavior
he's also used his knowledge of the
transcriptional regulation of cell fate
to create different neuronal subtypes
from embryonic stem cells transplanted
them into the spinal cord where they do
form the appropriate neural connections
now the work has obvious tremendous
implications and clinical neuroscience
most particularly in potentially
treating motor neuron disease in the
future but I think all of us can imagine
tremendous widespread clinical
applications of this sort of work in the
future we are delighted to have him here
as our Prize winner today we will talk
about shifting circuits for motor
control
well thank you Bob for that introduction
it really is a three-fold privilege to
be here this afternoon the first reason
is just because it's MIT and in the
context of neuroscience MIT is one of
those places that you pay attention to
actually about a year ago Nancy was kind
enough to host a bunch of people
including architects who are interested
in developing Columbia's own little
neuroscience venture and Nancy showed us
around the epicenter of Bostonian
neuroscience I can say that with
Clifford looking sternly on here so just
to be here is a real thrill
the second reason because this is a
Skolnick lecture and I regard myself in
a funny way as a sort of great nephew
once removed of Edie in the sense that
my doctoral thesis advisor was Leslie
Iverson who went to work for Merck at
Owings Park and as les writes one of his
pet projects was the development of
drugs based on substance P pharmacology
and he points out that Ed was a real
champion in that and I did my thesis on
substance P and its role in sensory
transmission so it's a privilege to be
here on that context and finally I
regard MIT as one of the mecca's of
motor control with Emilio and others
before him and so Emilio has been
arguing for many years about the primacy
of limb and muscle biomechanics and
synergy groups and as done molecular
biologists have taken a while to
appreciate the importance of this in the
context of thinking about the
organization of motor systems so a
little bit of what I want to do this
afternoon is to try and convince Emilio
and
you that we've finally seen the light
and that we from this reductionist
molecular perspective are beginning to
appreciate those aspects so it's an
exciting time for the motor system I
think as I'll try and convey and the
last thing in the context of Bob's
introductory remarks if you leave this
lecture theater with no other change in
your thought it's to try and convince
you that the spinal cord is not actually
a simple system it's damn complicated
and we don't understand it and maybe
we'll never understand it but it's what
drew us into the system in the first
place so we're stuck with it so what I
want to talk about this afternoon is
really to try and approach these systems
and circuits that give animals the
ability to act on demand that is to
process the sensory world that surrounds
them to implement their inner intent if
you like to purposeful action through
movement and the simplest of movements
engaged circuits at many different
levels of the central nervous system the
planning of actions and movements prior
to avert signs of this are thought to be
in part the work of circuits in cortical
centers and in other super spinal
centers but from the time of Sherrington
onwards about a hundred years ago we've
come to realize that the executive
component of movement deciding just
which muscles to activate at which time
in in which order and which sequence
though the problems and in large part
have been assigned to the circuits that
are resident in the spinal cord so at
one level if one wants to try and study
aspects of the expression of behavior
that problem reduces to knowing how the
nervous system engages muscles in this
precise pattern in in a context and task
dependent manner and within the spinal
cord some of the most sophisticated
forms of motor behavior are achieved
through
the mechanics of the limb whether it be
the iterative activation of flexor and
extensor muscles during locomotion or
the more complex arm and hand synergies
and manipulations that are involved in
reaching and grasping and retrieval
these are some of the features of limb
mechanics devoted to the motor system
and I think it's fair to say that
neither in locomotion nor in reaching
behaviors do we really have a very firm
grasp of the circuits that underlie
these behaviors and so this is what I
want to try and introduce to you this
afternoon from this molecular
perspective so just to introduce all of
you should I okay okay that better great
thank you
so this in very simplified schematic
form is a cross-section through the
spinal cord that introduces some of the
neuronal elements that are controlling
movement motor neurons generated in the
ventral spinal cord innervate individual
limb muscles and a variety of other
input so the problem here is really
reduced to twofold
how do motor neurons select muscle
targets in a way that conforms to the
biomechanical demands of the limb and
the second problem is how do the many
inputs to motor neurons organize
themselves in a way that makes sense in
terms of controlling motor neuron firing
and what is shown here are in schematic
form sets of inter neurons that serve as
local controls of motor output sensory
feedback monitoring the state of muscle
contraction and feeding that in its
simplest form in a mono synaptic
connection with the motor neurons and
not shown here are the descending
systems that engage these various
segmental spinal circuits and the output
here is shown in this EMG recording is
that a given flexor and extensor muscle
for example at a given joint are
activated in this precise ultimate
in phase so lest you think that this
binary activation is all that the spinal
cord can do if we consider for example
the locomotor step cycle then the limb
are typical and mammalian limb contains
some 50 to 60 different muscle groups
and the activation of these muscles
during the lift and swing and stance
phases of one step here involves the
synchronous recruitment and this is from
work by Trevor Drew of many different
muscles in this precise temporal order
and that these muscles can be classed at
individual joints into antagonists as
well as into muscles that serve a common
function in controlling the flexion or
extension of an individual joint that
joints images here so somehow these
circuits in the spinal cord and
descending systems have to engage this
complexity of muscle organization so in
this afternoon's talk I really want to
take these basic features of spinal
motor circuit organization to ask to and
perhaps three questions and importantly
and work by Eric Franke
and others have indicated that the final
pattern of connections in the spinal
cord at least from the sensory motor
control is achieved in an activity
independent manner and that begins to
suggest that there may be molecular
determination of the circuits that we're
looking at in these diagrams here so
this afternoon I want to address two
questions if we knew what the molecular
grain of neuronal subtype differences
were in the spinal cord could we use
that to infer strategies for specificity
in the wiring of motor circuits a
developmental question could we also use
cell type-specific patterns of gene
expression to interrogate motor
behaviors one neuronal class at a time
providing access that would be difficult
to achieve in other ways and lurking
underneath these two questions is this
issue of what really are the limits of
approach using these molecular
techniques if one wants to approach
motor systems at this system's level and
on the way perhaps I'll indicate
we're molecular approaches have got to
at least today so the first question one
can ask is what is the molecular grain
of information that is relevant to the
specification and organization of
neurons in the spinal cord and work that
we done over the last two decades or
more have told us that there's one
general class of proteins that are
particularly informative in revealing
neuronal subtypes and they turn out to
be transcription factors DNA binding
proteins that are expressed in the
highly cell specific manner and so we're
looking here in red at motor neuron
progenitors in in green at post mitotic
motor neurons expressed and generated in
one domain of the spinal cord and work
that I'm really just going to summarize
for it's sort of general principle here
is that motor neurons are generated in
the final ventral spinal cord together
with four major classes of inter neurons
that conspire to control motor output
and the different identities of these
neurons both in progenitor stage and in
post mitotic neurons can be recognized
by individual sets of transcription
factors and these transcription factors
are patterned here in response to an
extrinsic inducing signal in this case
the morphogen sonic hedgehog
so if transcription factors control
neuronal identity how do you make the
link between the identity of the neuron
and the connection of those neurons
through synaptic contacts with partners
to wire circuits and this raises the
general question of the link between
identity and connectivity which I want
to address for the first pass of this
talk and so it's clear that identity
controls connectivity we've shown that
other people have shown that how is it
achieved so one prominent view is a sort
of Sperry mvu that identity gives near
arms different surface labels and those
surface labels can be recognized by
incoming axons to distinguish one cell
type from another and while this seems a
compelling and plausible idea in fact in
the mammalian nervous system and even in
flies and worms has been remarkably
difficult to identify the
of the synaptic recognition determinants
we've known for an even longer time from
the time of Ramona cahal that neurons
with a common projection pattern and
common input and not scattered randomly
throughout the central nervous system
but they're clustered together in highly
stereotypic positions from animal to
animal within a species and across
related species so this is emphasizes
the role of neuronal position as an
important consequence of neuronal
identity in parallel with these
potential surface labels and in our mind
it raised the issue of what is the
relative contributions of label versus
location in the establishment of
connections and one reason from a narrow
focus in the spinal cord of paying
attention to neuronal position comes
from looking at the organization of
motor neurons in relation to the muscles
in the limb that they innervate and this
was a set of observations that was first
made by Georg Romano's now seventy years
ago looking at the organization of motor
neurons and muscle and so this is a
typical mammalian limb this would be
proximal distal hind limb so this would
be the foot this would be the ankle
joint the knee joint the hip joint there
and we've known for many years that
motor neurons that innervate an
individual muscle in the limb and not
scattered but the clustered into
so-called motor neuron pools what room
and this just shows that this
transcriptional specification of
neuronal identity extends to each of the
50 motor neuron pools that are found in
a typical and mammalian hind limb in
this case the mouse but what ramana's
pointed out is that the motor neurons
clustered into a pool the motor neurons
that are innovating related synergist
muscles at a particular joint are then
tightly clustered with their neighbors
innovating in this case ankle flexors to
produce a higher-order organization
which we've turned a column L or a
little column here and if you look more
generally at the organization of these
column ELLs within the spinal cord you
can see this precise relationship
between the dorsal ventral and medial
lateral
of these motor neuron clusters and the
limbs that they innovate so the most
dorsally located motor neurons are going
to innervate the foot
the next most ventral the ankle the knee
and the hip this is a remarkable feature
of organization that is conserved from
frog to man and invertebrate so it must
mean something here so what does this
mean in terms of the organization of
connections so one class of cells that
clearly respect this columellar synergy
organization of the sensory neurons that
provide feedback information onto motor
neurons so from the classical studies of
Eckles where they've used physiology to
map the specificity of connections
between a class of proprioceptive
afferent and their cognate motor neurons
what Echols and his colleagues showed is
that monosynaptic connections are formed
in an extremely strong robust manner
with homonymous motor neurons that is
Modena's projecting to the same muscle
but they're also significant excitatory
input into synergist motor neurons
innervating synergist muscles but these
one set of afferents take pains to avoid
forming contacts with antagonists or
unrelated motor neurons and when you
plot this out as a matrix you can see
evidence of this synergy group they're
stimulating one sensory afferent forms
connections at different weighted
strengths with four different motor
neuron pools so the problem from a
developmental perspective is how one
class of sensory afferents chooses among
fifty to sixty different motor neuron
sets a three or four to form connections
with with precisely invariant weights
which are necessary to control aspects
of limb movement and so we were
interested in testing the possibility
here that the motor neuron position
which is so tightly related to limb
muscle and sensory input might have
something to do with this specificity
process and so in order to do that we
wanted to do in this case initially a
sort of thought experiment this is the
normal organization of sensory afferents
and innovating different pools and
column ELLs along the dorsal ventral
axis what happens if we could strip
motor neurons of them molecular identity
but still get them to innervate
individual muscle target
and then look at the specificity of
innovation by proprioceptive afferents
if there was mayhem ensuing once we
stripped them then their food argue that
perhaps the surface label expressed was
important but if we saw an underlying
order here then perhaps it would suggest
that the position of these neurons
rather than their surface label might be
an important determinant and because we
know the transcriptional specification
of these motor neurons at Lin levels of
the spinal cord 21 of the mammalian Hox
genes are diverted to that it gives us a
way genetically of trying to inactivate
motor neuron identities we can't knock
out 21 Hox genes but what we can do is
knock out an essential host cofactor
that is required for the output of all
21 Hox genes and when we do that I'm not
showing you what we find is that we
completely ablate the subtype identity
of motor neurons yet they innovate
muscle targets or br-2 Brandon and you
can see that the cell bodies of motor
neurons that innervate a given muscle
target are no longer tightly clustered
but a scattered at random amongst the
general cohort so this gave us the
ability to look at the sensory
connectivity to motor neurons as a
function of their position in the spinal
cord and because this work is published
I'm just going to summarize the
conclusions of this which are shown most
clearly here so we have this matrix of
motor neuron positions if we strip motor
neurons of their identity or if in fact
get rid of motor neurons completely what
happens is the proprioceptive afferent
will grow to their normal dorsal ventral
medial lateral position completely
independent of the subtype identity or
presence of motor neurons themselves so
there is a sensory tier targeting system
which is independent of motor neurons
which gets century Athens into the right
position and when viewed from that
perspective it begins to make sense of
why evolution has taken such pains to
position motor neurons in a way that
conforms to their muscle targets because
unless you put motor neurons in the
right position they don't have a hope of
being innovated by the sensory afferents
are going to go to that coordinate
position so this began to produce the
idea that motor neuron position is
important because it puts neurons in a
position to
Seve appropriate sensory input turns out
that this is not a particularly new idea
although it surprised us because the
initial innovation of skeletal muscles
in the limb by motor neurons operates
along much the same principle the muscle
target doesn't provide information it's
the Limousin time that positions axons
and controls muscle cleavage in a way
that by the time the axons get to a
coordinate position there's only one
muscle that's cleaved and waiting fell
from there and in fact in flies from
were by my bait and by where's Gruber a
very similar sensory targeting scheme so
it begins to raise the possibility that
these target independent guidance cues
impose the requirement for neuronal
clustering and neuronal positioning to
achieve aspects of connectivity and in
our mind this raises the question of
whether this form of positional
information is true not just for sensory
motor connections but for the
connections of local micro circuits in
the spinal cord formed by inter neurons
so I'm going to spend a couple of
minutes providing evidence that this is
a general principle of micro circuit
assembly within the mammalian spinal
cord and so I pointed out earlier that
in addition to motor neurons there are
four major classes of inter neurons
there are two features here that are
important one is that we know that all
motor neurons derived from a single
domain but can diversify into 50 or 60
different subtypes so is the same true
for inter neurons that these major
classes can be fractionated into many
different sometimes that perhaps might
get us closer to the grain of
organization of the motor system and so
this is just the major Cardinal
sometimes distributing themselves what
happens if we focus on one of these
subtypes and ask how many different
fractionated subgroups can we identify
and this is worth the je bike off a
postdoctoral fellow in the lab has been
performing over the last couple of years
and he focused on one set of these inter
neurons the so called v1 inter neurons
which turn out to be inhibitory
interneurons and correspond to many of
the better characterized interneuron
subtypes the one a reciprocal inhibitory
interneurons and the
Renshaw cells in the spinal cord and so
J because he knew that the engraved one
gene defined this subtype was able to
make an engraved one Cree Rosa cross
label all the v1 neurons independently
used a different transcription factor to
label a set of GABAergic inhibitory
interneurons in the dorsal spinal cord
and did a molecular comparison to find
genes that are expressed in the v1 but
not in these di for inter neurons and
from that J's work identified eighteen
transcription factors that divide the v1
cohort into something greater than 25
different subclasses of interneurons
since there are four classes of inter
neurons if the same degree of diversity
operates it praises the rather daunting
issue that are at least a hundred
different molecularly defined subtypes
of interneurons sitting in the spinal
cord ventrally presumably to control
motor output and these are just a couple
of examples so in green are all of the
v1 neurons labeled in this genetic trick
and in red are the co labeled cells
defined by these transcription factors
and what you can see is that some of
this co labeling occurs in the dorsal
region and some of it occurs in the
ventral region our point I'll come back
to so the first question you might ask
is why do you bother to make this vast
diversity of inter neuron subtypes and
we don't know that a couple of
speculative thoughts one might be that
there are a lot of motor neurons so
maybe you generate an equivalent
diversity of inter neurons sometimes to
accommodate each of the different
merging the arms second way of thinking
about this comes from this sort of
diagram that these inter neurons serve a
central functions in mediating
descending control of motor output so
you couldn't imagine where four
different varieties of these v1 inter
neurons innervate essentially the same
set of motor neurons in terms of their
limb innovation but each one of these is
designed to receive input from a
different class of descending fiber to
give these descending systems are
labeled independent line control of
motor output so by the time you do this
and then
form this to different classes of
interneurons it begins to be plausible
as to why you'd need this diversity to
accommodate the different descending
controls and sensory control of motor
output we don't know that but we are
sort of interested in testing this idea
but the major point I want to emphasize
in this section is that when you start
to look at these 18 different subsets in
some detail you find something that
looks rather like the motor neuron
system where motor pools are arrayed
along the dorsal ventral and medial
lateral axis we find individual subsets
that are arrayed along the medial
lateral axis and as shown here for three
of these transcriptionally define v1
subsets the epicenter concentration of
these neurons is neatly arrayed along
the dorsal ventral axis so now we have
inter neuron subtypes located along the
dorsal ventral axis motor neuron
subtypes located and arrayed along is
there any relationship and does the
spatial relationship between motor
neuron and inter neuron constrain the
organization of the microcircuit and
remember that since dorsal ventral axis
in the spinal cord corresponds to
próxima distal axis in the limb we're
talking about a system that might be
dedicated for different circuits for the
control of muscles at different joints
so just to illustrate that this is in
fact the case I want to focus on a set
of inter neurons that a v1 derived that
expressed this math a transcription
factor that are located in extreme
ventral region of the spinal cord so it
turns out that the maffay neurons
correspond to this classical recurrent
inhibitory interneuron the Renshaw cell
here so the basic ventral cell circuit
has a motor neuron projecting to muscles
sending a collateral that recruits this
inhibitory interneuron which feeds back
onto the motor neuron
presumably to truncate the period of
muscle activity there's been confusion
in the literature as to whether Renshaw
cells like motor neurons also receive
sensory input or not some say no some
say yes so could that ambiguity or
uncertainty reflect precisely which
sensory neurons are projecting along the
dorsal ventral axis and perhaps only
some of them are capable
recruiting and innovating Renshaw sells
and so Jay has done a series of
anatomical studies that really confirm
that view so remember that the gluteus
motor neurons settle in a ventral region
therefore their sensory afferents go
ventral tibialis more dorsally foot even
more dorsally and what we find when we
label the Renshaw cell dendrites with a
motor neuron marker there when we label
the Renshaw dendrites with cow binden as
well as with maffay and look at sensory
input there we're using a vesicular
glutamate transporter which labels the
sensory terminals and defining the
muscle of origin by labeling the muscle
with CTB so it's transported into the
central terminals the gluteus afferents
co-expressed we glue one and CTB in this
sort of cyan color and innervate motor
neurons many half I mean innovate
venture cells half the rental cells are
innervated by the lutea saffron's many
fewer by tibialis and none by intrinsic
foot sensory afferents so what you find
here is a position dependent incidence
of innovation of Renshaw cells by
sensory afferents they're arguing that
for this class of inter neurons only
certain sensory actions that are
normally could have reject in the
ventral region have a hope of innovating
and this is true not just for this
aspect of Renshaw cell circuitry but for
the recurrent loop itself and so this is
supported by physiology where when we
record together with jorge montes group
at columbia from rental cells we find
that gluteous formed strong excitatory
inputs very few inputs from tibialis and
no mono synaptic inputs from the
intrinsic foot so what seems to be
happening in this situation is you're
building micro circuits as a function of
neuronal settling position in the spinal
cord that are dedicated according to the
muscles that are going to innovate at
different joints so the hip joint
innovation here the motor nerves
innervate the hip form this classical
recurrent inhibitory circuit as well as
having sense
the input and that the opposite extreme
the foot motoneurons never bothered to
give off a collateral knows rental sells
never bother to inhibit motor neurons
and there's no sensory input so these
and other studies on different classes
of these v1 are beginning to argue there
there's no such thing as a canonical
motor neuron circuit in the spinal cord
but that circuit depends on the muscle
mechanics that they're going to innovate
and by inference along the dorsal
ventral axis of the spinal cord so why
would you bother to design these
different circuits well one possibility
is from limb mechanics the degrees of
freedom at different joints very rapidly
so if you look at the elbow you're
basically operating in one plane where's
the hand as many degrees of freedom so
maybe in order to meet those functional
demands of muscles at different joints
you have to build different circuit
organization so if we come back to the
position versus label issue at least
from these studies in the spinal cord it
seems likely the neuronal position has
as important a role in determining the
final pattern of connectivity as any of
the presumed surface labels most of
which are still remain to be identified
so where this shakes down in terms of
the relative contribution of label and
location we're in the middle of finding
out and in the spinal cord position in
progenitor cells along these gradient
morphogen axes gives you identity
identity then translates back into a new
position of motor neurons which then
determines connectivity so position and
connectivity patency intricately linked
in the spinal cord and if this is true
in the spinal cord then it seems at
least plausible that it may be true in
other regions of the CNS so when you
look for example these classical
homunculus not that they actually
represent anatomical perfection it's
hard not to believe that the
relationship between the organization of
motor cortical neurons or somatosensory
cortical neurons and the periphery there
might not have similar functions or if
you look at the different sub nuclei of
the amygdaloid complex which looked just
like motor pool
why are you clustering these neurons in
a way if you're not using it to simplify
the problem of connectivity so we're
interested in exploring these ideas in
addition in the spinal cord but also
seeing how well they extend to other
regions of the central nervous system so
this is one developmental example of how
you can use in your own elide entity to
tease out principles of circuit
construction in some cases surprising
principles such as the emphasis on
neuronal location for the rest of the
talk I want to move to the idea that
neuronal identity can also be useful in
extracting
features of the relationship between
motor circuit organization and limbed
motor behaviour and much of the work in
rodents has traditionally been focused
on the locomotor cycle the step cycle
here where as the work in primates and
humans has tempted to emphasize this
evolutionary more sophisticated aspect
of object manipulation and retrieval and
grasp and so these are highly
specialized processes giving rise to
this sort of you know extraction of this
quote from Barham the slight chance of
reaching these skill tasks have an
inherent failure component in there so
can you even begin to approach problems
of reaching in rodents like mice and so
here in wish ORS group has made an
argument that there are conserved
modules of reaching and that there's a
sort of a breakdown of these different
components that can be analyzed from
rodent or primate so the initial lift of
the hand and the limb the advance the
pronation and then the grasp of a target
retrieval here so we've been interested
in asking whether in fact we can use the
mouse to study aspects of skilled
reaching and then begin to probe
elements of the circuit organization and
in one view we're trying to deal with
the problem that motor systems have been
advertised the rapidity and refinement
during leeching tasks so as you know the
idea of planning motor commands and
activating muscle eventually producing a
sensory feedback which is relayed back
into the central
nervous system arrives too late to do
much good in terms of the online
updating of a motor plan so the nervous
system has designed shortcuts if you
like to deal with this so-called delay
problem one is to have a copy of that
motor command transmitted at various
regions in the central nervous system to
provide more rapid update and when that
copy is integrated with the actual
sensory feedback these system service
comparators to modify and monitor errors
between planned and actual motor and
performance there and a second system
that has been used is to use these local
segmental sensory gates further down in
this system to modify the information
transfer between sensory and motor and
so what I want to do is give you
examples of both the way in which an
analysis of circuitry might provide
insight into the copy and gate system
during a skill reaching task in the
mouse and so these are were studies
performed initially by Ayman azim who is
set upon the challenge of trying to
develop these motor reaching tasks in
mice so what he did is he took a mouse
separated it from a food pallet by a
thin perspex slit and then monitored the
kinematics of limb trajectory as it
reached for this target with a series of
cameras at different angles and so we
could visualize the full pour with a
marker and the food pellet target and
monitor this in kinematic time and I'll
just give you one example of one of
these reach tasks so here is a mouse
reaching for a pellet through the slit
and we can monitor a variety of
parameters that trajectory the velocity
of the four paw as it's reaching for
this task in a way that is at least
beginning to resemble the sorts of
analyses and studies that have been done
in primate systems there and the first
conclusion was that independent in
wild-type animals of the success of a
she grabbing the food pellet that
trajectories and velocities of the four
limb during these tasks whether it's a
hit or miss were remarkably similar
and this is just shown here so in the
end the successful reach is largely a
part of their late stage coronation and
much less a part of the initial reach
trajectory so I'm and convinced himself
this sort of behavioral assay might be
amenable to the dissection of certain
elements of motor circuits of the fallen
level and then the question is which
circuits do you study where do you begin
to tackle this very complicated program
of motor output and in this
consideration we were intrigued by
studies that have been carried out for
the last couple of decades by bra Ulster
Marc in Sweden and Tadashi Isha in Japan
who focused on a set of propria spinal
neurons that are found at cervical
levels of the spinal cord that have a
last order-- promoter excitatory input
to fall in level motor neurons that are
controlling limb muscles here so this in
principle might provide one way of
looking at their last order input here
and ultimate initial studies have shown
that when you sever this descending
branch you get defects in the reach but
not in the grasp or retrieval supporting
the idea of the modular organization of
reach in mammals what intrigued us more
was this second branch of the same
neuron that is descending the spinal
cord ending in the lateral reticular
nucleus our pre nucleus which then
provides output to the cerebellum so
this branch here then might begin to
look like a copy of a motor command
being delivered to motor neurons here
and this is a somewhat strange
organization compared for example to the
traditional motor efference copy systems
that have been identified in the spinal
cord
for example the ventral spinocerebellar
tract here which receives a copy so that
our story goes of input two motor
neurons and relays that up to the
cerebellum here we have a variant of
this where there's a similar projection
to the cerebellum but it's welded
together with input to motor
and so in this traditional system it
places an emphasis on the information
being provided to the VSC team neurons
being exactly the same as the
information to the murder neuron to get
an accurate output or an accurate
internal copy if you like whereas in
this system even though this is not the
only input to motor neurons you're
pretty sure that the information being
transmitted to the cerebellum is a copy
of the information being transferred so
maybe in order to achieve the
sophistication of motor control you have
to design these internal copies through
a variety of different mechanisms so we
were interested on the basis of ulster
marks work and we've been collaborating
with bra in these studies and seeing
whether actually equivalent propia
spinal yawns even exists in the mouse
and we have some evidence from
physiology that they exist because if we
record from appropriate spinal neuron
and ant rudramma Clee activate by
stimulation of the lateral reticular
nucleus as well as from motor neurons
you can get a classical anti drum expire
collision arguing that there are neurons
in Mouse cervical spinal cord that
project in both directions to both
target regions we were more interested
in the idea can we identify molecular
lis these propria spinal neurons and use
that to begin to manipulate this set of
neurons in particular to try and ask
whether this a sending internal copy has
any role in calibrating or modifying
motor control and so the feature of
these neurons from this molecular
perspective is that these a it's a
lateral last order excitatory promoter
inter neurons here and of these
different in Turner and sometimes the
only class that conforms to that anatomy
are these so-called v2a neurons which
can be defined by a transcription factor
checks 10 so we then ask the question
amongst the checks 10 v2a neurons do any
of them conform to the propria spinal
neurons defined by a projection to the
lateral reticular nucleus and to motor
neurons we know the v2a
form these inputs to motor neurons do
they also project to the lateral
reticulum
so to do that we made a mouse in which
checks ten drives Creary companies and
then we injected an ad ngerous o ceated
virus encoding both channelrhodopsin and
a fluorescent protein into cervical
levels of the spinal cord here the
fluorescent protein is important if we
look in the lateral reticular nucleus
you can see a very dense innovation of
the lateral reticular nucleus neurons by
neurons that a VTOL a derived that
originate from cervical spinal cord so
this says that as a population there are
neurons that project to the lateral
reticular nucleus and to motor neurons
but does an individual neuron have this
bifurcating innervation patent and to
test this we again labeled these neurons
using the checks ten Cree control we
injected CTB to retrograde li label
these neurons from the lateral reticular
nucleus we injected wheat germ
agglutinin into fallen muscles is
transported into motor neurons hops into
the v2 a neuron and then we asked
whether there were neurons that are
green we wheat germ positive and CT be
positive so here's the green neuron that
CT be positive is wheat germ positive if
you overlay and what emerge is about
one-third of all of the VTA neurons
conform to propria spinal neurons by
these anatomical criteria so if we can
identify these neurons can we now
manipulate their function and ask
whether there's any impact on reaching
behavior and so we've done this in two
ways I'll emphasize one of these ways so
by virtue of the fact that we can
identify v2n neurons we can express a
diphtheria toxin receptor in those
neurons we can then inject it theoria
toxin and kill those neurons very
effectively and we see dramatic errors
in reach trajectory the problem is that
only a third of the v-2 A's are propria
spinal and by killing the neurons we
block the pre motor output as well as
this more interesting
a sending internal bra
here so we wanted to do something that
allowed us to focus on this branch of
these neurons with a greater degree of
selectivity in fact focus only on that
third of the total set of v2 any runs
and so what we've been trying to do is
find ways of selectively initially
activating but eventually in activating
this a sending branch and look at the
consequences from motor control to
address this sort of internal copy route
here so way we've tried to do that is
again in the Czech stem cream ask to
inject channelrhodopsin into these v2 a
marked neurons and then place a light
probe and photo activate the terminals
of these vitória neurons in their
lateral reticular nucleus now the first
thing one would need to worry about here
is that there are many instances where
terminal activation with optogenetic
methods results in back propagating
spikes and then we might activate the
motor system so i'm and bra tested this
very rigorously and while local
electrical stimulation in the lateral
reticular nucleus is sufficient to
activate and to dramatically the propria
spinal neuron no amount of
photoactivation over a wide range of
stimulus parameters ever resulted in any
activation of the propria spinal neuron
so we conclude at least at this level
that in this as in many other neurons
photo activation of terminals doesn't
result in back propagating spines yet we
know that photo activation is very
effective in triggering the activity of
the target lateral reticular neurons so
with this in mind we then performed a
behavioral study to see the consequences
of activating or over activating this is
a sending pathway so if we take a mouse
that is expressing channelrhodopsin and
in the absence of light monitor the
trajectory you see what you've seen
before there's a relatively direct
trajectory to the target with a typical
velocity if we now turn the optogenetic
um system on and activate and perform
the behavioral task then what you find I
think you can see here
there's a severe impairment in the
trajectory and reaching this animal is
clearly showing abnormal trajectories
abnormal velocities and does a very poor
job in fact when we monitor this there
are no successful reaches in the
presence of activation of the PN
terminals in the lateral reticular
nucleus and you can see these dramatic
changes in trajectory now admittedly
this is a fairly crude approach to this
system we're activating this system in a
way that is perhaps non-physiological
nevertheless I think it does show that
activation of this ascending arm
uncoupled from the promoter is producing
a severe abnormality in motor control
and motor output internalizing the
question of how is this system operating
we know that activation of the PN
terminals activates the lrn neurons
which provide their exclusive output to
the cerebellum and so it begins to
suggest a pathway where somehow the
cerebellum is involved here in receiving
this information and relaying this
information the other important
experiment that I'm Anand Braun noticed
is when they record from motor neurons
under this optimization protocol with
some delay they actually see an a series
of excitatory inputs to the forelimb
level motor neurons from stimulating
this PN pathway in the lateral reticular
nucleus and the time delay is not
conclusive but he begins to jet suggest
that one of the outputs of the
cerebellar system perhaps through the
reticular spinal is to provide a
descending excitatory input back onto
the motor neurons now you could say that
we just messed up with the anti drama
activation and what we're really doing
is anti dominantly activating this input
part of the reason for thinking that
that is not the case is that when we
sever the lrn input to the cerebellum we
completely lose the motor neuron
response here arguing that this is a
cerebellar output pathway so we're now
getting dragged in
into the cerebellum which i think is a
bad sign because no one who ever goes
into the cerebellum ever comes out of it
but nevertheless we're forced into that
sort of world so one way of thinking
about what might be going on and I
stressed that this is speculative here
is under normal conditions the activity
of these propio spinal neurons under
steady state provides an lrn input both
to the cerebellar cortex and to deep
cerebellar nuclei and some clever
learning strategy which the cerebellum
is good for and ensures that the DCN
output is precisely matched by an
inhibitory Purkinje derive signal to
compensate for the input from the lrn
and there's a balanced motor output when
we photo jam this system by activating
these terminals we induce an imbalance
the cerebellar hasn't has time to learn
this new world and so we over activate
these deep cerebellar nuclei which
provide input to the reticular spinal
and trigger the motor system so in some
ways this system for the control of our
movement bears parallels to what some
people are thinking in terms of
psychotic control of eye movement in
terms of the cerebellar involvement so
maybe there are common strategies in
motor control independent of whether
you're moving the ocular muscles extra
ocular muscles or the loop and so we're
interested in exploring this possibility
by looking in more detail at what the
lrn is doing and beginning to delve and
somewhat tremulously into cerebellar
circuitry and output so just to end I
want to give you one other example of
the way in which this reach task might
be important and informative in
dissecting out this time not a sending
and descending loop pathways but local
circuits that exist within the spinal
cord and this is this idea of their
local sensory gates that a modifying
sensory input motor output and that
controls muscle contraction and perhaps
the classical example of a gate in the
spinal cord was identified some 50 60
years ago by Mike Fortis and KFOR
was studied by Echols which is this
strange phenomenon of presynaptic
inhibitory control of sensory motor
transmission the idea is that the
sensory neurons that are forming mono
synaptic connections with motor neurons
are subject to presynaptic inhibition by
a set of GABAergic inter neurons and the
classical Eccles study showed that when
you can find physiological ways of
activating these gaba neurons you get a
suppression of the motor neuron epsp
that is exerted presynaptic li more
recently we've been interested in the
specificity so is this a general
population of gaba neurons that are
growing out and some of them just
accidentally happen to a light on
sensory terminals or their selective
subsets of gaba inter neurons summer
which had devoted to the task of forming
these presynaptic inhibitory synapses
and work that Nick Bentley and Julia
Cashman did first of all by visualizing
these synapses so in green we're looking
at a motor neuron surface membrane this
is one sensory terminal shown in blue
and each of these little red butonce
here are the butonce of one of these
gaba inhibitory synapses and they showed
that this is a highly selective subset
of gaba neurons we have a transcription
factor that defines these neurons and
more interestingly when we take the
sensory terminal way these gaba neurons
will not tolerate any substitute
synaptic targets they withdraw their
axon and shrivel up so they're seeking
out sensory neurons we know something
about the molecular basis of that
recognition but for what I want to tell
you today the most important aspect is
that these GABAergic neurons unlike all
other Gavan neurons in the spinal cord
synthesize gaba through the expression
of the gantt two or gad65 gene whereas
every other inhibitory interneuron
expresses GAD one or gad67 so GAD two
together with this transcription factor
gave us in principle a molecular entry
point to this precise subset of
inhibitory neurons that form presynaptic
contact so together with Josh Wong at
Cold Spring Harbor we got hold of again
two
I scream Mouse used adenoviral
associated vectors to express the same
channelrhodopsin fluorescent protein
fusion and if we look at a single
sensory terminal we can see that this
fluorescent protein nicely stuns the
presynaptic Bouton's sitting on this one
terminal all of which co-expressed the
gantt two genes so we can reliably with
viral infection Express about 80% of
these gaba pre-boot ants on sensory now
so we have a way in principle now of
activating the gaba presynaptic neuron
selectively so when we take a Hemi
spinal cord preparation and this is work
by Andrew Fink a graduate student in the
lab shine light on these neurons and
record from them then light very
effectively and trains these neurons at
frequencies between 1 and 50 Hertz in a
linear manner so we now have genetic
access to this selective subset of gaba
presynaptic inhibitory neurons and when
we record from identified motor neurons
while stimulating the sensory input and
then activating these inhibitory neurons
optogenetic lee we can see just what
Eccles saw a reduction in the EPS see
elicited by sensory stimulation so this
proves that these transcriptionally
molecularly defined interneurons are the
inter neurons responsible for
presynaptic inhibition so in the 60
years that have followed the
identification of these neurons we still
don't have any real idea of about the
behavioral relevance of presynaptic
inhibition because pharmacology doesn't
distinguish these from all the other
gaba inter neurons
so in principle presynaptic inhibition
is kind of good because it selectively
blocks one of the inputs to a
postsynaptic neuron where's the
postsynaptic inhibition shuts off the
neuron to all of the many inputs but
what is the behavioral consequence of
that so andrew set out to try and
eliminate just these presynaptic
inhibitory blue tiles and examine the
consequence for motor behavior using
this skilled reaching task and so he
could do this again with this diphtheria
toxin reset
trick he's in Creede driven by gad65 old
gang who expressed at fear toxin
receptor in these neurons let the mice
recover and then at some point applied
diphtheria toxin so pre diphtheria toxin
application under these conditions you
have nice gaba pre-boot ons in pink
studying these blue sensory terminals
after you deliver diphtheria toxin you
completely denude the sensory terminals
but all the postsynaptic inhibitory
Bouton's
on motor neurons and other neurons are
still intact so this gave Andra the
ability to ask is there a behavioral
consequence of the elimination of
presynaptic inhibition or is this system
simply redundant with the very prominent
postsynaptic inhibition so the first
thing that he found in these reach tasks
is that soon after application of
diphtheria toxin the success of these
reaches dropped dramatically to close to
zero so something is going wrong if one
does the kinematics here again this is
the prior to the administration of
diphtheria toxin you can see a
relatively normal trajectory from origin
to target what about after eliminating
the gaba pre terminals so this is a
mouse in which just that set of gaba
inhibitory interneurons and their
presynaptic terminals have been
eliminated and in a relatively acute
manner what you can see i think is a
profound reaching defects the animal is
sort of moving backwards and forwards
explains why an attempt fails here there
essentially no successes under these
conditions and when you look what you
see is again a very dramatic behavioral
consequence during these reach tasks
here and in fact if you monitor velocity
you see this sort of oscillatory
behavior which i think you throw on the
video every forward movement is
compensated by a backward movement there
and these have if you do the
transformation periodicity of 20 40 and
60 Hertz whatever that means so getting
rid of gaba presynaptic Bouton's
produces this defect in back
an anvil together with my theoretician
colleague Larry Abbott at Columbia have
been thinking about this in the context
of what the role of presynaptic
inhibition might be in terms of the
control of motor behavior at a given
limb right and this analysis that I'll
show you sort of occurs some earlier
work that helps hands Holborn had been
thinking about in terms of studies that
he'd done in cat and so the idea here is
to build a model in which we consider a
single joint and the angle of extension
and the torques
driving extension which increases this
angle of flexion which decreases it and
then also to introduce a component of
sensory feedback and it's presynaptic
inhibitory weight and so the basic idea
here is that if we're going to extend a
given joint here activate the motor
neurons activate the muscle there will
be a compensator presumably sensory
activation of the antagonist flexors and
that will then feed back in the form of
a mono synaptic connection to the
antagonist motor neurons and produce an
opposite on behavioral response so in
this view one role of the gaba pre
inhibitory neurons is to shut off the
antagonist input to motor neurons under
conditions in which you want to achieve
a smooth pursuit if you like of this
joint extension so when you modulate we
base this and then you simulate joint
extension under the conditions that
gather pre neurons are active usually
near nice smooth extension what happens
then as we did experimentally if you
take this model and try and eliminate
these gaba pre neurons under those
conditions there's nothing stopping this
sensory feedback from activating the
antagonist flexor at a given joint and
if you model this then what you find is
that you have a system in which joint
begins to extend and then it
reverberates in this oscillatory manner
because this this alternation of
activation of flexor and extensor and
flexor and extensor and if you plot this
the stimulated trace in the presence
presynaptic inhibition in the absence if
we look at the actual data here in terms
of a distance to pellet that you could
measure many other things you have an
oscillatory behavior that in principle
could suggest that one of the functions
of these presynaptic inhibitory neurons
is to prevent the consequent
reverberation at flexor and tail
extensor systems are they given joint so
for this study then it begins to point
how understanding the genetic provenance
of one set of inhibitory neurons can
reveal something that so far was not
unappreciated previously and the real
question now is that if by extension the
extensor activation is blocking the
flexor sensory afferents there has to be
a high degree of specificity in the link
between the extensor input and the
inputs to these gaba pre inhibitory
neurons and Pablo rudiments work over
many years as argue there's a highly
sophisticated organization of
presynaptic inhibition in the spinal
cord so we're now interested in chasing
that down to see whether this logic can
be moved one neuron upstream or two
neurons upstream of these last order
presynaptic inhibitory neurons and we
can do this these days because you have
genetic access to these neurons can hop
retrograde Lee using rabies virus and
try and trace the neurons that are
avoiding this input so here the idea is
to look at these local sensory gates
that are having rather a profound effect
on the fidelity of movement and see
where that gets us so just to finish
I've told you a lot about the intricate
details of circuitry in the spinal cord
and the way the one can begin to use
genetic identity to build up these
circuit maps and a general question that
you might ask is is this a particular
feature of the spinal cord something
strange in the spinal cord or are there
lessons to be learned about the
organization and function of circuits in
other regions of the central nervous
system for example in near cortical
circuits and these are early days yet
because the information on the identity
and organization of neurons are
contributed to these circuits is less
secure but I think there are a few
that one whom we begin to conclude first
of all in cortex as in spinal cord
there's a very high diversity of
neuronal subtypes you look at peter
samajis working-class burgers work in
the hippocampus and you see many many
different engineer and sometimes the
stereotypic organization of settling
position and topographies in cortex are
just as evident as in the spinal cord as
we talked about work from Jeff Mathis
and Sue McConnell and others has
indicated that there is a
transcriptional determination of
neuronal identity at least in the
colossal and descending projection
neurons so these studies begin to
suggest that although it's early the
cortex may use very many of the same
principles of organization that have
become to be clear in the spinal cord
and then the final thing I want to point
out is that the cortex is you know
famous for its experiential modification
and I don't want to leave you with the
idea that the spinal cord is rigidly
determined by these molecular probes
Molecular programs I think it's very
likely that the details of engineer and
connectivity as you begin to look at
finer and finer resolution will Halep
elements where there is an activity
dependent sculpting of these fine into
neuronal organizational connections but
in order to get to that level of
resolution we need to be able to find
the inter neurons that are potentially
substrates for experience and then
explore them one class at a time and
we're in the middle of trying to do that
so in general I think the principles
that operate in one region of the
central nervous system are going to be
very much the same but perhaps with
different weights so some regions place
an emphasis on experience and activity
and others on these molecular programs
and I think no region this is a guess
are likely to escape the dual
combination of these two sets of
programs so I'm going to stop there and
just highlight the people who've done
this work all of the work on position in
the spinal cord of interneurons was done
by jay bike off with help
physiologically from jorge montes and
Estelle drøbak I'm a Nazim developed
this reaching task in mice and began
looking at
the internal copies mediated by propria
spinal neurons this has been a
collaboration with broster mark and John
Gianni in umeå in Sweden and we've had
lots of input and ideas and polemic from
our Churchill and and john cracker
who've been telling us that we're
wasting our time that we're ignoring
them and in fact invoking them to come
and help us a little bit the work on
presynaptic inhibition is that from the
graduate student Andrew Fink together
with Josh Wang and thinking about what
presynaptic inhibition is good for his
Larry Abbott so I'll leave this there
and then be happy to take questions
thanks very much
yes yes we're coming to grips with this
rather strange result at the moment
there have been many previous attempts
at FETs and other people who tried to
look at Quora lots of changes in
presynaptic nerve ition I think this is
the first time that we have cleanly
eliminated presynaptic inhibition and
see this behavioral deficit whether this
has clinical relevance I think is an
interesting point there are many
apocryphal studies of highly specialized
motor programs where motor performance
increases dramatically in Danish ballet
dancers for example where people have
studied EMG is and one of the
interpretations of those studies is that
something changes about the functional
weights of those circuits and one
interpretation of these studies by
Nielson is that the strength of
presynaptic inhibition could be
modulated in some way so we don't know
yet these are relatively new and
unpublished studies but they do begin to
suggest that there's a particular
function of this presynaptic inhibitory
control that can't be substituted by the
elaborate postsynaptic inhibitory
mechanisms
this is a sinusoidal oscillation it
comes about just from simple circuitry
we're falling back on a proportional
circuit control yes I mean there are
many things that will induce tremors of
descending origin this is one particular
local origin I think it remains to be
seen to what extent many of these
clinical abnormalities that look like
oscillations really reflect changes in
the efficacy and efficiency of
presynaptic inhibition we don't know I
mean these are thoughts and there's no
real validity in this but one way of
thinking about it is if you relied on a
spare Ian lock-and-key like label system
the job of the sensory afferent is to
sort through 50 different motor neuron
subtypes and choose the two or three
that it really likes and ignore the rest
and we don't know since we don't know
what those recognition systems are what
the limits of specificity in those
systems it may be that this is trying to
design in protein recognition a system
that is just too complicated so the way
that I think about this
positional yeah positional contribution
is that it simplifies the problem for
later molecular recognition if you only
have to choose between two or three or
four potential target partners maybe
molecular recognition can do a better
job of that than sifting through the 1
in 50 needle in a haystack so that's one
aspect of this the second thing is that
I want to emphasize that both of these
programs are an inevitable consequence
of the molecular identity of the motor
neuron is just in one case the molecular
identity is devoting itself to putting
neurons in the right
place and then the other two putting
surface labels on neurons they both may
be equivalently taxing in terms of
molecular routines and machinery how to
settle in a position or how to recognize
and maybe the nervous system was just in
the sense divided and conquered by
passing the problem out to two different
systems rather than trying I mean it's
not a very compelling answer because we
don't know with one exception any of the
recognition we don't even know where the
recognition systems really operate it
could be that everything is a very
elaborate positional grid and that
sensory afferents are programmed through
some other set of cues to get to that
point so we were surprised by the
prominence of position as a determinant
of microcircuitry in spinal cord and are
still working through that phase of
amusement think of the implications of
this for spinal cord injury but in terms
of reestablishment of
you could answer that better than me
Clifford what I would say is that there
are very I mean this is in a sense where
activity begins to rear its head because
as you know following high spinal cord
transactions particularly in animals
providing active input to spinal
circuits has a dramatic impact in motor
output in terms of the amplitude and
pattern of the EMG from studies of
Reggie Edgerton and Susan Harkema so
what is activity doing that is changing
the weight of circuits so that you
reconstruct effective motor output so
the implications as I see it is that if
we can really map the organization of
the circuits that exist that a
controlling motor output in this fine
degree of resolution we have a hope at
least of asking the question under
conditions where you're now using
sensory input as a surrogate for
descending input what has changed in
circuit if we knew what has changed
maybe we do a better job of enhancing
that change under conditions that answer
reliant on sensory feedback and
locomotive treadmill activity so I think
the understanding of the organization of
these circuits in spinal cord will have
an impact but it's more in in the
relationship between the the
reactivation of circuits after injury
than in coaxing descending core of the
spinal axons to do better although it
may have implications there too